[Music]
thank you
all right no yeah you don't look okay
dude I didn't it's not even that I did
anything
it I
we got home so it's Cash's birthday
yesterday happy birthday brother happy
birthday yeah thank you we popped by I
was waiting I already said it before but
I guess I should just say it on the mic
yeah it doesn't count unless you say
live yeah so we pop by we hang out at
his place for a bit we leave early 11
30. okay
get home at midnight me being me I'm
hungry I just have like a little peanut
butter sandwich throw a little milk Down
the Hatch just to you know okay warm
milk not even warm milk cold milk yeah
go to bed kind of gross yeah kind of
gross on Halloween night
to warm up a glass of milk yeah well I
just I just went with a little milk okay
just like just a little bit of milk yeah
okay steady needs a little milk okay
Daddy needs a little milk just just
something to put to shut the stomach up
and I wake up in the morning and I eat
for real okay
I don't know what happened now Grant I
don't I don't consume too much Dairy
these days so I don't know if just that
little bit of milk my stomach was like
what is this
but I you know like
getting ready for bed about 15 minutes
later I'm like oh knife is going through
my stomach I'm thinking what the hell
I'm [ __ ] water like actual water not
milk no I would assume it would be milk
that you'd be [ __ ] no it's like my
stomach kept all the dairy and then
squeezed out
I was on the toilet so long the on the
first round that my legs went numb okay
and I it was you kind of like that yeah
so you can stand up and fall forward and
hit the shower door and die
and that's how they find your body yeah
I don't even know the time exactly I
retired I was on the toilet so long
it blew my back out when I stood up my
legs were all numb I was trying to get
back to bed I'm just like
it's got that milk just blew my ass out
[Laughter]
that's rough yeah and then I crawl back
in bed and then
Elena wakes up she's like
what happened and I just said I'm never
drinking milk again
and then I fell asleep what time was it
I have no idea and then I I woke up this
morning
pretty early
and I just felt ran through
Halloween Halloween is just exhausting
there's just no way around it uh whether
if you go out or if you don't go out it
catches up with you one way or another
you eat too much candy or
I mean that's pretty much it yeah that's
the only thing that's what it does for
me yeah I eat way too much candy can I
just say
I just should have drank if I knew that
was gonna happen to me I just should
have drank yeah yeah true
so you were sober having tequila shits
so you didn't even have the fun part
yeah
I went home early I'm gonna get to bed
early yeah because you know
I was talking Hunter the other day we
were talking about me being late and he
goes so you're selfish and since then
I'm like you know what I want to be less
selfish I want to be on time I want to
try to be on time it's not fair that I
do that to people today
yeah literally I'm having this whole
also thought that counts
yeah and then so what happens I'm like
damn and I'm getting I'm getting out the
door this morning I'm like is it selfish
that I had the milk oh yeah no you know
but I'm just like I just should have got
wasted yeah he looked horrible when you
walked in like sad genuinely like sad
yeah and then you sat down and you were
like I brought Candy
you were most depressed anyone's ever
said that you want some I ate so much
[ __ ] candy yesterday
that I don't want any of that
and that's a bad bag too
[Laughter]
I mean it's not great there's Reese's in
it that's really all that's exciting
yeah I bet you want the Almond Joy I
mean I did eat one of those yesterday
and I like coconut but I bit into that
and I was like why the F how was this
still economical that they make these
yeah they can't they can't be making
money off these people don't buy them
oh they oh they do man do they they're
called British and they're dumb really
yeah British people eat Almond Joys yeah
they do Almond Joy yeah all right it's a
joy yeah
what do you think they call it that
oh that's the Beatles I guess
when you think they come up then
I don't know Ringo I've got a bullet
hole in my head
Jesus
oh yeah we got new merch by the way
that's not funny
new merch
[Laughter]
Ryan's sitting here to make sure we
promote this and it's been 10 minutes
and we still haven't done it that's why
we're firing these people why because we
could do what we want I kind of want to
promote this okay fine
check it out look how happy I am
well rested who merged by the way
that one's cool though I actually really
like this one no it's like an old like
liquor store tea or mine Jim killed it
on all these yeah Jim you murdered every
time like he literally ruined it yeah
like you stink no no no no no no these
are awesome
um I love that one the most the blue
hoodie
yeah and where can they where can we
find these
of course tmgstudios.tv the same place
where you can also find all of our bonus
episodes every single one
there's like 200 of them now
so this is one of those like I do want
some of that actually yeah this is one
of those bags with a child lock on it so
we're not gonna be able to get into it
without a blade
there we go
hmm
thank you did you see the tick tock of
the dad that's like way too pissed that
he got no trick-or-treaters no
he's like it's [ __ ] [ __ ] I bought
all this candy he walks the window he's
like I don't see one human being out
there I don't get it
funny damn
and I was like laughing at it because
Kelsey was like so pumped yeah
to get trick-or-treaters yeah we put
like we carved jack-o-lanterns we put
them outside we made our house look so
welcoming yeah open the gate put the
lights on
and we got like two the first one we're
like you can take as much as you want
like we're not getting many
trick-or-treaters so we hold the bowl
out we're like you can take as much as
you want yeah and he like picks one
thing and puts in his bag
and then the other kid goes up and just
grabs like an entire handful and sticks
in his bag yeah and he says thank you
and the other kid goes I'm not that
greedy
walks away
like Damned
wow shade
not even shade not just straight to his
face yeah wow kids are ruthless
I'm not that greedy yeah
just
it's like fat ass yeah
well we know who's getting diabetes
between us
mm-hmm
yeah now go ahead get a little chew time
in I thought Halloween was over no it
ain't over man I was really excited
Halloween's forever
not surprising yeah you know what I'ma
load up I'm just gonna pick my Loadout
right here
I don't think that's gonna help your
stomach
no it's isn't this what caused it
no that's the thing you don't know what
caused it no it was like a temporary
food poisoning
that's rough